so uh this is literally zero connection
to the topic i'm about to talk about but
um while doing the setup uh i noticed
this piece of popcorn which um
would date from back when the oscars
aired
[Music]
so today i'm going to talk about
something that has been on my mind
since the debut of zack snyder's justice
league
for reasons that i will reiterate in
case people don't remember
but it really got me thinking about the
topic of
whether or not creators
ip holders the people who produce and
manage the entertainment that we watch
do they have a responsibility to address
the behavior of their fans and
if so to what degree
and what are the positives and negatives
about trying to do that
and it's just something that's been
rattling around in my head so i
mentioned
zack snyder's justice league in case you
don't remember
during a charity live stream and i
believe it was the day it premiered or
it was in the lead up
it was right around the time the thing
dropped zack snyder
was on this live stream it was a charity
live stream to raise
money to help combat suicide which
tragically snyder's daughter took her
own life
during the production of justice league
so obviously this is something that is
not only very close to his heart but is
very regrettably kind of inextricably
linked
to the production of that film so it
it made a lot of sense and it was a
wonderful cause one of the things that
he did
at the time uh which was very surprising
to a lot of people
was he actively distanced himself
from the organization geeks and gamers
who was actually running the live stream
he was on their live stream
and he actively said that
he is not directly linked to them
and he deliberately did not endorse them
and said
i forget his exact words i might put up
a clip
[Music]
on our donation page we still have the
geeks and gamers logo i just want to say
that
i really um we talked about this and you
know
we're really not affiliated with geeks
and gamers as far as i'm concerned
and i really just want to make that
clear and i also want to just say
um you know in light of recent events i
think we really
you know if justice league teaches
anything it's about coming together
and we there's no room for hate and
i just think that it's important it's an
important message and of course
you know as um the father of the asian
children it really
it's close to home for me and i just you
know i just really want to put that out
there that we all
you know there's no room for hate it was
a pretty direct call out now
i'm gonna try and not get into this too
deep because i don't really want this to
be a finger wagging session at geeks and
gamers i don't
do call outs i try not to be a drama
channel
but really quickly geeks and gamers is a
bit of a
let's go with divisive entity in geeky
fandoms
they are they are anti-sjw
types progressivism and diversity is
ruining our entertainment
style pundits geeks and gamers have
um a fair amount of that style
of content and again i
don't know enough about them to make any
specific accusations but i'm saying
that's the vibe
of the organization it just is and
what was really surprising about that
was not only just sort of the
well to be blunt about it the balls of
zack snyder to call them out
on a live stream they were hosting while
some of them were right
there their faces were on the screen
aside from just whoa
factor of that it stands out because
this kind of call out by a creator
from people who like and vocally support
his work
for behavior that he feels is
unacceptable
is a rarity it doesn't happen very often
now that just kind of got me thinking
about it
in general because let's be honest fans
of anything are very passionate people
and passionate people have the capacity
to generate
a lot of love a lot of affection
a lot of loyalty a lot of anger
and depending on where they decide to
direct
that anger they can be
very destructive and
how that links to the specific media
that they are fans of
that's not really something i'm prepared
to parse right now
i will say broadly speaking that there
are some
properties multimedia properties that
are just never going to call out this
kind of behavior because
their brand honestly kind of feeds that
and not to
try and throw anybody under the bus but
something like call of duty
it would feel very bizarre for a violent
militaristic style game
would call out its fans for their
abrasive behavior that would be weird
but something bit more within my sphere
something like doctor who
which does have toxic fan elements star
wars
which does have toxic fan elements and
understand i'm not saying that
people's beliefs make them toxic i'm
talking about behavior here so when i
say toxic that actually has nothing to
do with your particular views
people who to use doctor who because
it's my go-to people who like
the current era of doctor who and love
jodie whitaker and think that chris
chibnall is doing solid work
are just as capable of toxic behavior as
people
who hate jody whittaker and gymnel now
that having been said in my experience
at least
the people who are already generating a
lot of negative energy have a tendency
to lean more on that but
any kind of fan can turn bad and can
exhibit just horrible behavior and this
is something that
happens across the board there was a
story not all that long ago
about the actress who played cho chang
in
the fifth harry potter movie and the
amount of
racist vitriol thrown at her by supposed
fans
of harry potter i say supposed no they
probably were fans
but they cared more about what they
thought
that property should be than about the
human being
that they flung their venom at
and at the time the producers behind
that and this is stuff we've only
learned really recently
the producers basically told her
don't ever talk about the racism stuff
don't bring it up if asked
don't address it they
decided to pretend the problem wasn't
there
which i think is a very common tactic
especially when you're dealing with
something like
a studio because they care about their
bottom line it's something i come back
to
over and over and over again and it's
not in their financial interest
to risk alienating or
getting on the wrong side of a chunk of
the most loyal fans because
while there can be some elements
people who just like to stir up crap who
come into a fandom find something to
um get angry about and then just go at
it
most of the people who get really
passionate about this
are fans whether they get constructively
passionate
or destructively passionate and it's
going to be natural
as unfortunate as it is
for a studio to look at that and go
uh you know we really don't want to
um to alienate anybody because the
simple truth is
toxic fans money spends just as good as
positive fans
which i suppose is part of why while it
was surprising that zack snyder
said what he said it's less surprising
given that
he's an individual not a corporation
warner brothers wasn't ever going to say
anything even close to that
in regards to anybody they never would
and let's be clear warner brothers has
benefited over the years
by basically keeping its mouth shut
about certain fan behavior i mentioned
harry potter already
and i don't know
if people remember this now because
a lot of folks seem really vindicated by
zack snyder finally getting to put out
his version of justice league
but i remember back
when batman v superman came out and a
lot of people didn't like it
i'm sorry i think it was garbage but
the wars the flame wars that went
on between marvel fans and dc
fans and from the perspective i had it
felt like dc fans were starting more of
the crap but
i say that as a marvel fan who wasn't
venturing really into dc
uh dc fan spaces and was only seeing dc
fans invade the fan spaces i was in so
i obviously have a skewed perspective on
that but that kind of nonsense was why
imdb got rid of its forums
like i remember hearing the news that
imdb
shut down its entire forum's uh
section and i remember just i at that
point i bowed out of them a while ago i
remember just thinking oh
that's probably a good idea because it
just got
so ins and i don't suspect marvel vs dc
was the only thing that
that soured the forums but it was
certainly what i saw
well you know i say that and i was
seeing i was like good grief
but at the end of the day it was spats
on internet forums is that
something a company should be speaking
out against
i don't know i mean that's part of the
thing is i don't really have a firm
answer to the questions that i posed at
the start of this
and i think it's easier to boil it down
to
individual primary creators a bit more
than talking about the corporations
because it's always going to be the
interest of the corporations to
basically
take a step back and say nothing
because again even with things like say
when kelly murray tran was
insanely massively harassed by
a certain stripe of star wars fan in the
wake of
the last jedi by and large disney and
lucasfilm
left it to the individuals to stand up
for her
and didn't really do too much which
again
corporate angle makes sense especially
with the fans who are angry because they
already
hated people like ryan johnson anyway so
he can decry
this and placate the people who
recognize it as horrible things that
shouldn't be happening to anybody
but also isn't going to take off anybody
who hasn't already ticked off
this is the kind of calculus that goes
on at the corporate level it's
insanely cynical but bringing it down to
individuals
or even bringing it down to something as
small as
youtube i mentioned earlier before
talking about geeks and gamers i
really try and make a point of not doing
call outs or
take downs or causing internet drama
and part of the reason for that is i
have
twice now been on the receiving end of
youtubers with significantly larger
followings than me
doing videos that in some way
derided me or were takedowns of things
that i did and in both cases
i saw their fans and their supporters
descend on my channel
and just be there to harass me and
my subscribers and my commenters
and neither one of those people
to the best of my knowledge ever
made any kind of indication hey
don't bother this person i mean
i'm not trying to hold myself up as a
pillar or a paragon but
i try really hard to remember when i
talk about
individuals on here that you know
don't do personal attacks not here not
in my comments definitely where i have
control over it but not
on twitter if you're angry about the
work someone has done
that they've produced if they made a
piece of art that you don't like
and if you're upset because it is tied
to a piece of media you care about and
they made something you don't like
you can complain as loudly as you want
about the piece of media but the instant
you start in
attacking individuals that no that's not
okay
and there were no kinds of um
guidelines like that given by these
youtubers
and of course even if they'd done that a
lot of their fans wouldn't have listened
which i suppose is another reason that
maybe a lot of times they don't
speak out about this not youtubers not
directors or producers or studios
because
they know it's not going to stop the
behavior anyways that to me
just makes it a coward's move
well we can't stop it so we'll do
nothing
speaking of someone who's been on the
receiving end of
a lot of vitriol at several different
points
and probably will be again let's be
honest
if you could do anything
to trim down the volume
of people coming and attacking me
or whoever you've decided to highlight
for your fans that they might go after
i certainly would have appreciated it
i'm not sure i would have necessarily
thanked you for it because they still
would have descended on my channel
regardless but having been on the
receiving end of people who
did not do that no if it helps at all
it's worth doing
assuming you care that's kind of the
other thing
they have to actually care although
i should be clear it's not a risk-free
proposition
and not just from the corporate
element that i mentioned the sort of
let's not alienate fans
handling it wrong can turn the entire
thing
worse i think probably the best example
of that
is ghostbusters 2016. this was a reboot
that a lot of people
were not happy about i wasn't happy
about on principle just because it's a
reboot
and especially after seeing it and
honestly the movie's fine
it's fine but i was annoyed with it
because there's absolutely nothing about
it that required a continuity reset
there's nothing that needed to be a
reboot there was nothing going on with
that story
or characters or world or aesthetic that
required them to go
okay we're hitting the restart button
that thing before that is no longer
ghostbusters now
this is ghostbusters that rubbed me the
wrong way
but there were also a lot of people who
just got very very very angry because it
was all women
and were frankly sexist apples about it
i'm not gonna mince words i don't really
care about the feelings of people
who went that road however
in attempting to respond to that some of
the things that
the cast and crew did with things like
that
somewhat infamous now shot of them all
standing around with the sign that said
girl power
it didn't feel like condemning fan
behavior
it felt like poking the bear and the way
that
some of them would speak and i'm not
sure this was actually the intention
of any of the people involved in that
film who spoke out against that but it
it was interpreted this way and it
it wasn't difficult to interpret some of
it this way
it came across as anyone who is
saying that this is a bad idea or we
shouldn't be doing this
they're mad at us because it's all women
and speaking of someone who thought it
was a terrible idea but had no issue
with that like
don't let me in with the rest of them
please
so there is an argument to be made that
that
attempt to call out behavior of an
admittedly
damaging and toxic sliver of fandom
just made it feel like they were blaming
a much larger chunk of fandom than was
actually the problem and ended up
alienating more people
now that's incredibly hard to prove
in any meaningful way because i have no
way of knowing
what the box office or the support for
the film might have been if they had not
responded in that way
i can only speculate but that certainly
is the impression that i got left with
and if i
as a relative lay person came away from
that
i guarantee you that pretty much anybody
involved in the industry came away with
a similar if not much
uh more number and
uh money lost backed version of that
same
conclusion i think if i were gonna try
and come down
somewhere on this
the closest thing i'm going to come to a
hard line because i think ultimately all
this is incredibly situational and like
i said i don't have answers
but i think it is very difficult
for studios directors
you the face of youtube channels anybody
to try and regulate
the behavior of fans toward other fans
because that's just kind of stepping
into something that
only kind of involves you like it
involves your work
but you know is that really your place
to step
in because there's a fan war going on
uh i mean it i don't think it would hurt
every now and then for somebody to
somebody with like creative authority
as opposed to like a studio head because
nobody cares what they think
as far as public statements go and they
know that that's why they don't say
things
but for somebody with uh with a creative
stake in creative clout in the project
to go hey
you know i understand you you all care
you're passionate but
folks you need to you need to take a
breath and and calm down a little
because this is supposed to be fun
for everyone involved i don't think you
can really go too wrong just
having somebody say that now again if
they need to
i do however feel increasingly that
studios especially but even
directors
or the people who run these projects
manage these ips
they do have a responsibility to their
own employees so when i look back
at something like what happened with the
fifth harry potter
and what happened to katie liang
and the fact that warner brothers told
her to basically suck it up and not talk
about it
instead of protecting a child
a young teenager who
they hired and then
refused to help or assist
or protect no
that's not okay
these people work for you
you are making money off their back
off of their work the least you could do
is have their back
and not just throw them to rabid fans
to be torn apart in social media to the
point that they have to quit
various social media platforms which
happens
frighteningly often now i do feel a need
to clarify
i'm a little bit more iffy if fans are
coming at a
it's usually an actor but somebody
involved in a project
for something that they did that has
nothing to do with that project
that's probably not something you want
to step in
but when you're basically dealing with
people who are
employed by you brought into this world
by you
who are being harassed simply
by existing and in many cases
just by existing as someone who isn't
cis
male white and heterosexual
uh yeah no don't don't leave them out to
dry
and just whoever you are
if you're a youtuber if you have a
notable twitter following
if you are a director if you run a
studio
realize that what you put out
in the world can
and will drive people's
actions people will
do things to other people
based off things that you tell them
that doesn't mean you have control over
over them they still are deciding to do
these things that on their own
but if you're on a youtube channel
and you decide to do a takedown video of
somebody
you are unleashing your fan base at them
whether you appreciate that or not it is
what you're doing and if you run a
studio
and you're casting a major franchise
film that people care a lot about
anyone who you cast in a role is going
to be in the crosshairs potentially of a
lot of people
and if you're gonna bring them in into
that situation
you owe it to them
to try and protect them and try and
wrangle those fans
if you can and again the ability to do
so is very limited
but i think how many people were
pleasantly surprised by zack snyder
calling out a sliver of fandom
that he took issue with and he felt was
not in the spirit of what he wanted his
work to represent
part of why that's notable is because of
how rare it is
and maybe it shouldn't be that rare
i know it's scary i know it is
no easy thing and i
certainly for one hope i never have to
do it
i don't ever want to have to distance
myself from people who've supported me
but i'd like to think if it ever comes
to it
i'll do it if i have to being in the
public eye producing consumption
intended for the largest participle
audience
is not easy
it's draining it's exhausting
and thinking about how many people your
work is impacting if you have a
substantial following
or your work uh brings a particularly
devoted fan base
that's an intimidating thing to think
about
but you still need to think about it
or at least maybe if you're large enough
hire somebody
to think about it that's what pr
management's for
but yeah i guess i'm going to wrap it up
there
i feel like there is some degree of
responsibility but i
can't draw a line on where that is
and whose precise responsibility it is
in specific situations
but when fans run
rampant in the name of love for
a property or personality
and the people behind that property or
personality
remain silent it's a tacit endorsement
you're not saying they should stop
and you probably should those are my
rambling thoughts on all this
what do you think about this topic in
general it's a difficult one to try and
get fully on top of and i'm certainly
interested to hear what you have to say
just do it politely whatever your
thoughts are drop them down in the
comments and let's talk about it
i have a patreon and that is how i am
able to do this
without the support of my patreon
backers i would not
be able to cover my bills this is in
fact my entire living at this point
any amount you're able to support is of
great assistance and there are rewards
for every tier
from being able to see the docket early
to getting to vote on
topics to a patreon exclusive discord to
getting your name in the credits which
you'll be seeing
shortly but even if you can't do that
like share subscribe
the bell hey if you're feeling ambitious
those all help me out as well
keeps the algorithm from completely
forgetting me
but i'm not gonna tell you even have to
do that
because while i do feel a certain amount
of responsibility
at the end of the day you
are the council and i'm just running the
meetings
to the best of my ability and until next
time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
um